je le dis bah il dit il rappelé les bons
on a opéré
parce que contrairement à vous très
humide rôle dans l'essor macro ni les je
vous le dis mélenchon mais non je vais
discuter avec jean françaix raison de
région je vais discuter je connais bien
avec honneur au 6e rang mais je vais
discuter avec les maires de mon
arrondissement je vais discuter que les
adjoints je vais discuter que les
scientifiques disent que tout le monde
lui contrat fait chier tout le monde moi
je dis jurés l'avaient réouvert je suis
qui n'est pas votre cas on obtient des
résultats parce qu'on est dans le
dialogue
je suis content a raconté sa famille on
est capable de détruire leurs voiles ont
détruit rouge vous êtes dans l'ain
victime gpac way monsieur badin fond
monsieur et je vous ai dit j'ai un kit
pour les nuls parce qu'ils seraient pas
besoin mais fellah jours après c'est
vrai que nous à ce jour sur vos
références et fans là puisque si
stéphanie dépendance et le passeport
sanitaire hier mettez vous à jour mais
si je sais qu aurait mal informé et je
suis dans celle annoncée au salon son
sujet en racontera les dépôts ne vont
pas le faire le qr code scholly il a à
côté du vaccin astrazeneca dans un super
congélateur hiver a pu arriver à plus
chauds concernant le pas sur scène va la
liste elle donnerait son passe-temps
sanitaires
j'ai des pâtes restaurateurs hâter la
ville moi j'ai des potes person shooter
tchadien ça marche pas personne le
nombre c'est une lubie alors vous agiter
les peurs et nous c'est ce qu'on en fait
juste vraiment bien fait besoin de
manigod on a envie un peu de loin on
aimerait savoir ce qui va se passer là
il ya plein de gens qui nous regardent
ya des téléspectateurs qui ont envie de
savoir des restaurateurs des gens là qui
sont dans le commerce des gens qui ont
envie aussi de 2,2 de savoir si les
terrasses vont rouvrir ce qui va se
passer cet été quel est le calendrier je
sais que vous avez des infos est-ce que
les terrassements rouvrir me met fin mai
début mais qu'est ce qui va se passer
oui me mais nous aurons c'est pourquoi
pas céder au gouvernement vous a dit le
mime et vous allez ouvrir cet été
seulement oui les terrasses d'accord moi
parce que factuellement c'est pas mes
chiffres ces chiffres de santé publique
france 2 10% des contaminations se font
à l'extérieur d'accord à l'évidence il
faut qu'on avait l'extérieur et je vais
même vous donner un deuxième secousse
mais qui est pas ma chronique comme
unique qui joue du bon sens parce qu est
dirigeant d'entreprise c'est prévoir
aussi et j'anticipe le président
république et l'annoncé qui prendra la
parole trois semaines avant je vous
faire un scoop
s'il tient sa parole il prend la parole
jeudi
et jeudi il annonce et jeudi il annonce
l'ouverture mi mai donc oui journaux
jeudi le président la république devrait
prendre la parole
oui si on oublie melville voulons
prévenir mais nan mais c'est juste
factuelle en mon travail ce que je pense
d'eux on été choisi c'est sûr je suis
d'humeur maintenant en janvier je crois
sur le même plateau vous aviez dit on va
faire le confinement je vous l'annonçais
n'y a pas eu le confinement janvier donc
vos sources faut quand même les revoir
malheureusement le qr code
oui attal malraux l'ont annoncé et
l'union européenne est en train de le
nom alors l ouverture solitaire sur
l'ouverture la réouverture vous ne
m'avez toujours pas donner d'arguments
scientifiques pour m'expliquer le lien
entre ces restrictions et ces fermetures
et l'épidémie parce que ça n'a rien à
voir
il est la raison scientifique moi je
suis venu alors laissez nous laissez le
vous répondent non à l'arrivée j'étais
là dessus on a un point d'accord on a un
point lens joue comme le souligne ça
fait un an que je parle des
purificateurs d'air notamment dans les
salles de classe ça fait un nom qui
effectivement vers on n'en parle pas et
ne le relève même pas et ça je ne
comprends pas et j'espère que vous aurez
plus de succès que moi l'atteindre l
affiche du haut lieu de l'avarié et
enchaîne les chiffres de la suède
donc c'est 1354 morts par million
d'habitants la france 1504 donc c'est
bien comme ça